porque estamos viendo que durante esos
diez años en Francia que tenemos una
expansión de los conflictos que se
desarrollan ahora en el medio ambiente
ahora hablamos de un conflicto entre
entre Turquía y kurdos y porque la
comunidad urda quiere más protección
también está enojada hoy día en París
hay que recordar que también hace más o
menos diez años también son tres
activistas también este purdas también
que que fueron también matados también
en en París Entonces eso también es una
reacción un enojado y también hay que
entender en esta situación que tenemos
una expansión de los conflictos que
tenemos en otros países que va más allá
de las fronteras de esos países donde
hay los conflictos
mire en Francia hoy en día aún no
mantiene alertas terroristas Después de
los ataques del 2015 y del 2016 Le
quiero preguntar Aunque Todavía es muy
pronto después de este tiroteo Qué
efectos traen este tipo de
acontecimientos violentos en la
sensación de seguridad para para los
parisinos
Bueno creé un efecto de de de pánica
total o sea tenemos tenemos un miedo en
París que existe todavía que sigue
existiendo tras los años tras lo que
conocimos con el bataclam Tenemos
también un miedo también de de tener un
ataque también terrorista pero también
esos tipos de personas también con
motivos este en este caso motivo racista
aislada que pueden tomar las armas que
pueden también o sea cometer crimen en
cualquier parte ahora hablamos del
distrito diez pero hay que recordar que
también es es cualquier persona que hoy
día en París puede también estar en
momentos de riesgo lo vemos ahora es un
centro kurdo cultural kurdo que fue
también este en el centro del del motor
del tirador Pero tenemos también una
peluquería al lado Entonces el peligro
existe Y tenemos canciones también entre
entre comunidades también en este caso
turcos y y kurdos y y el miedo también
sigue insistiendo en la población sobre
todo en París donde hubo esos atentados
varias veces viene y finalmente se
pronunció el presidente de Manuel macron
diciendo que fue un ataque horrible y
que el objetivo evidentemente eran
kurdos
han ordenado las autoridades francesas
además fortalecer la seguridad alrededor
de los centros cursos en París Usted
cree que por lo que se ven las noticias
hay temor de que pueda haber nuevos
ataques o Esto fue un hecho aislado
Yo pienso que en este caso hay que ver
también lo que se va a decir en los
próximos en los próximos días en las
próximas horas ahora hablamos de también
un autor también que tiene también o sea
motivo racista que está conocido y que
de por un lado también
quizás está aislado Pero se tiene que
saber detrás si hay una manipulación
pero va va a seguir las pensiones entre
las comunidades turcas y curdas en
Francia en los próximos días y los
próximos meses eso yo creo que yo pienso
que eso eso queda bien claro